[Musica]
Chiari ristrutturato casa negli ultimi
10 anni
Chi ha ristrutturato casa negli ultimi
10 anni con un architetto accanto
Scommetto che pochi di coloro che hanno
ristrutturato casa senza architetto
accanto Sono felici del risultato
ottenuto e soprattutto pochi
percepiscono questa sensazione di
benessere a 360 gradi che ognuno si
aspetterebbe di trovare in uno spazio
domestico
non so che
perché Ige non è solo luci e candeline
e anche un modo di progettare e
pianificare
IG rappresenta un'atmosfera il che
rappresenta una sensazione che ha a che
fare con il senso di familiarità di
comodità di accoglienza di sicurezza
igé ha come obiettivo il raggiungimento
della felicità permanente tramite un
senso di appagamento a lungo termine E
per vivere con questo
[Applauso]
E per vivere con questo Mood Bisogna
saper riconoscere le piccole cose che ci
fanno stare bene grazie a degli ambienti
accoglienti che ci permettano appunto di
riconoscerle e di viverle liberamente Ma
che relazione c'è tra benessere a
pagamento e architettura Come può un
architetto aiutarti ad essere Igea
l'architettura è quella disciplina che
ha come obiettivo la organizzazione
dello spazio in cui viviamo sia Esso una
città ossia su un bagno degli ospiti con
tutto quello che c'è nel mezzo
aggiungendo perfino agli oggetti di
design il grande Le Corbusier diceva
l'architettura e il gioco sublime
rigoroso e magnifico dei volumi nella
luce
un architetto è formato per gestire
spazi e volumi affinché essi siano belli
fruibili e funzionali
una corretta pianificazione urbanistica
rende la città più bella ma è in grado
di gestirne anche la viabilità il
traffico è in grado di posizionare
correttamente i servizi quali ospedali
uffici scuole è in grado in funzione del
numero di abitanti previsto per
quell'area di dimensionare correttamente
e posizionare correttamente gli spazi
verdi il tutto in un gioco incredibile
di equilibrio tra estetica funzionalità
fruibilità numeri statistiche e così via
e una casa una casa progettata da un
architetto La riconosci
indipendentemente dai tuoi gusti
personali quella casa è bella fruibile e
funzionale in funzione delle esigenze di
coloro che la abitano è una casa bella
fruibile e funzionale anche una casa
intelligente sostenibile e che rispetta
l'ambiente
e quindi una città o una casa bella
fruibile e funzionale cosa genera
benessere e questo benessere che altre
sensazioni provoca in noi familiarità
comodità sicurezza accoglienza proprio
quei termini che hanno definito IG e
quindi che relazione c'è tra Ige e
architettura
un'architettura ben pensata e ben fatta
è sicuramente Ige
io mi occupo principalmente di case e le
case negli ultimi anni si stanno sempre
più avvicinando ai temi cari al concetto
di ghighe i clienti sempre più spesso mi
raccontano nel raccontare nel farmi le
loro richieste le raccontarmi le loro
aspettative mi parlano di case che fanno
dell'accoglienza
informale Serena rilassata il loro punto
di forza amici e familiari vengono
invitati in case appunto informali
fluide dove la distinzione tra lo spazio
di rappresentanza e gli spazi privati
ormai non esiste più
le cucine sono sempre più aperte sui
soggiorni non li usiamo più solo per
cucinare li usiamo per
bere un bicchiere di vino fare quattro
chiacchiere incuranti di piatti lasciati
nel lavello o di odori di cucinato i
televisori che una volta erano al centro
dei nostri spazi delle nostre zone
giorno stanno mano a mano scomparendo
dietro ad ante scorrevoli dietro ad
armadi proprio a favorire chiacchiere
risate e i divani stanno diventando
sempre più grandi per evidenziare questa
zona destinata a chiacchiere risate e
stanno diventando sempre più profondi
per favorire una seduta rilassata comoda
informale e i tavoli i tavoli anche loro
sempre più grandi se non c'è spazio sono
sicuramente dei tavoli allungabili
perché il tavolo non lo usiamo più solo
per mangiare ma lo usiamo per impiattare
e stappare
impastare fare i compiti
e magari anche scalzi e poi ci sono gli
ingressi sempre più spesso troviamo
ingressi aperti sulla zona giorno hanno
frequentemente un armadio per i cappotti
degli ospiti e per le loro scarpe
si Bada moltissimo alla funzionalità
sempre più spesso mi viene richiesto di
trovare posto per una piccola
dispensa per una piccola lavanderia e
per un piccolo bagno ospiti perché sono
comodi perché ci permettono di
utilizzare le zone private in totale
Libertà senza costringerci a correre a
rimettere in ordine all'arrivo
improvvisato di un amico
e le luci le luci sono fondamentali per
creare un ambiente accogliente
finalmente stanno scomparendo queste
distese indefinite di faretti incassati
nei controsoffitti dei nostri soggiorni
e finalmente le luci si stanno
riscaldando Una luce calda e ben pensata
crea un ambiente accogliente una bella
casa illuminata male è una brutta casa
bisogna nella progettazione della luce
pensare alla luce di fondo illuminare
correttamente uno spazio in modo
uniforme ma bisogna soprattutto badare
alle luci di accento ovvero i lampadari
sui tavoli Non demonizziamoli non
demonizziamo le lampade da terra le
lampade da tavolo le care vecchie
abat-jour sono proprio loro che ci
permettono di creare quell'atmosfera
giusta per sorseggiare una tisana per
leggere un libro
e poi i colori i colori stanno
diventando sempre più chiari avrei detto
che erano i miei clienti a non avere
coraggio ma in realtà ci stiamo
avvicinando a questo nuovo spirito
quindi ben vengano i
colori chiari tutti i toni dei bianchi
tutti i toni dei beige altra richiesta
che ricevo molto frequentemente è quella
di trovare spazio per le piante piante
grandissime perché sono proprio loro a
permetterci di ritrovare il contatto con
la natura
e quindi possiamo concludere che lo
spirito igge sta sempre più invadendo le
nostre case perché è uno stile di vita
che in questo periodo storico ci
permette di ritrovare le cose importanti
i familiari gli affetti la serenità la
pace il tutto con estrema lentezza
e Ricordiamoci di chi può aiutarvi a
rendere la cassa la vostra casa IG
ovvero colori Quali sono stati formati
per gestire spazio volumi affinché siano
belli fruibili e funzionali E se proprio
vuoi fare da solo ne ricorda che una
corretta pianificazione ovvero pensare e
decidere prima di andare in cantiere è
il trucco per avere una casa Iggy
[Applauso]